c'est l'été il fait chaud les gens
apprécient le soleil bien loin de
lakovic 19 ans vient s'amuser il fait
beau on en profite bah je pense pas que
les gens font tellement attention non le
québec est entré dans sa septième vague
les moyennes hebdomadaires des nouveaux
99 ont doublé depuis le mois de juin
malgré cela peu de gens prennent des
mesures additionnelles non plus
maintenant non un vaccin et puis je
pense qu'elle menait fois avancé faut
pas reculer pense que les limougeauds
sont encore l'immeuble ou non ça va
changer donc non change pas nos plans
pour l'instant pour cette immunologiste
la santé publique envoie un message
contradictoire en appelant à la
vigilance sans ajouter de mesures se
claquent les messages sont clairs je
pense que la plupart des gens ont
l'impression que la pandémie est presque
terminée mais elle est loin d'être
affaiblie ailleurs au canada la pandémie
reprend de la vigueur les provinces de
l'atlantique voient leurs nouveaux cas
augmenter en flèche c'est inquiétant
pour moi la vie continue et je suis les
règlements mais on est vaccinés qui
demande autres règlements on voit les
chu en ontario au lac au vide force
plusieurs à revoir leurs plans de
vacances oui les plans de vaucanson
changer parce que l'aco vide elle est
toujours là et comme vous me voyez nous
on a nos masques on continue les mêmes
habitudes au québec l'incompréhension de
la période d'isolement en cas de maladie
semble favoriser la propagation du virus
c'est pour ça que ça se compte 1 min ans
parce que les gens ne respectent pas
cette règle de dix jours c'est ce qui
fait en sorte que ça se contaminent
beaucoup sur le site web du gouvernement
il est inscrit que l' isolement doit
durer cinq jours et que le travail peut
reprendre
après cette période à condition de
porter le masque durant un autre cinq
jours mais définitivement cinq jours
après beaucoup de gens
c'est que beaucoup de gens qui mettent
du virus le ministre christian dubé
souhaite responsabiliser les québécois
face à cette nouvelle vague il tente
surtout d'éviter d'imposer de nouvelles
me dur en plein été à quelques semaines
d'une campagne électorale ici marie
josée paquet comme radio canada montréal